You said that in school, a lot of people bullied you and didn't like you.
Now that you're famous, have any of them tried to, quote unquote, "apologize" and become friends?
If so, what did you say to them?
I wouldn't say "apologize"; there's been a lot of concert ticket requests!
And I think one of the most awkward things that anyone ever said to me was,...
..."Well, my my. How the tables have turned."
But to be honest, I don't have that kind of vengeful spirit in myself.
And I never did. It was just more that,...
...and I say this with so much genuineness from my heart, is that...
...bullying really stays with you your whole life.
And it really, really never goes away, and I know...
...you're using words like "superstar" and "most Googled" and...
..."billions of Youtube videos" but,...
...I was never the winner; I was always the loser.
And that still stays with me.
And do I wanna stick it to anybody? No.
I just wanna make music.